[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
24 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform podcast.
I am Fransesc
Campoy and I'm here
with my colleague Mike Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey, Francesc.
How are you doing today?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty good.
Pretty good.
Lagged, but very to be
back to the United States.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
We're actually in
separate places right now.
This doesn't happen very often.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Yeah.
We will tweet about the
pictures of our studios today.
They are precarious,
I going to say.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
You're down to Mountain View.
I'm all the way in Kentucky.
It's lots of fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And actually, since we're
traveling, both of us,
we were not able to
interview the same person
at the same time.
So what is the
main content today?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So I interviewed Terrance
Shepherd with one
of our coworkers and previous
interviewees, Brian Dorsey.
Terrance talked to us about
Google Cloud Platform support.
It was a really
interesting interview.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I still haven't heard
the interview itself.
I will soon.
But I'm sure there's going
to be-- did you ask questions
but what is the funniest
thing that has ever happened?
MARK MANDEL: I didn't quite
get the funniest thing.
But I definitely got some
really interesting stories
about problems that people have
had on Google Cloud platform,
like common things or weird
things and some solutions
as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Yeah.
Looking forward to that.
And after that interview we also
have the question of the week.
What is the question of
the week about today?
MARK MANDEL: So it's not
something necessarily quite
as Google Cloud Platform
related, but definitely
cloud related and a question
we get quite often, which
is how to go about
coordinating or connecting
say like an app engine app or
something else on Google Cloud
Platform to other cloud
services we have at Google,
such as drive or calendar.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That is actually a question
that I've had many times.
So I'm sure that
many of our listeners
will consider that
pretty useful.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I think so as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But yeah.
Before that we're going to
go through the cool things
of the week today
with [INAUDIBLE] is
there's actually two of them.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Yeah.
So the first one is
something for some reason is
very near and dear to my heart.
I have a particular love
for Deployment Manager.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Which is surprising,
because I assume that these
things you can make them
with a big, big makefile.
I don't know.
MARK MANDEL: I really
like Deployment Manager.
So if you're not familiar
with Deployment Manager,
it's a way to declaratively
basically specify
the infrastructure you're
on on Google Cloud Platform.
I was super happy to
see that recently they
have support now for Pub/Sub.
So if you want to create
topics or subscriptions
within Deployment Manager, you
can do that through that now.
You couldn't before, which
is really, really cool.
Pub/Sub is a tool that I love.
It's a messaging published
subscribe service that we run.
It's super, super powerful, and
lets you build some really nice
distributed systems.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That is actually really cool
because it was the last steps
so we could get rid of our
deploy script for Cloud Spin.
Now everything can
actually be done
with just one deployment manager
file, which is very nice.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I was thinking that would be
really great for the Cloud
Spin.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
We still need to write it.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
Now what's the second cool
thing of the week that we found?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The second
cool thing of the week
is actually with certifications.
And it's about ISO
certifications.
So recently, we got two
more, two new certifications
for the Google Cloud Platform.
And I'm sure you
have the numbers.
I know that one is for
privacy and the other one
is for security.
But I never remember the names.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
We did ISO 27017 for cloud
security and ISO 27018
for privacy.
Those are the two new ones.
And we also renewed our
ISO 27001 certificate
for the fourth year in a row.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And this actually covers
basically all the things
in Google Cloud Platform.
So data flow, big table,
content arranging, data prog,
container registry,
Compute Engine, App Engine,
and et cetera, et cetera.
Basically, all the things
that you can imagine,
they're covered by
this ISO certificate.
So very often it's a requirement
depending on the industry
you're a part of.
It's always good to know
that we've got you covered.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
And I think just the
general takeaway,
we really care about security.
We really care about privacy.
This is just another thing
that we do in that area.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, absolutely.
And we'll put the link
on the show notes.
But there's a
cloud.google.com/security
that's something that you
want to learn more about.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
So why don't we get stuck into
the interview with Terrence
with Brian joining
me as co-host.
Does that sound good?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
That's good.
Let's talk to both of them.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds great.
We are joined today
by Terrance Shepherd
who has agreed to talk to us
about Google Cloud Platform
support.
How are you doing
today, Terrance?
TERRANCE SHEPHERD:
I'm doing pretty good.
MARK MANDEL: That's
pretty great.
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: Are you?
MARK MANDEL: I'm pretty good,
having a good day so far.
We have a bit of a
guest host today.
Unfortunately,
Francesc traveling
and I had a minor
medical emergency.
So we had to reschedule
a few things.
But Brian Dorsey is here with
us again as a guest host.
How are you doing today, Brian?
BRIAN DORSEY: Hello.
Hello.
Good day.
I hope you're all healthy.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
Yes.
Much better.
Got a clean bill
of health today.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK.
Good.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
So Terrance, why
don't you tell us
a little about yourself, what
you do, the things you do
a Google, et cetera, et cetera?
TERRANCE SHEPHERD:
So my job title
is called technical
solutions engineer.
It is under the cloud
platform support umbrella.
And what I basically
do is-- customers
come to the support team
when they're very anxious
or they have a problem.
And I'm there to help guide
them to a solution that
makes them less anxious
or resolves the issue.
MARK MANDEL: So, Terrance,
we talked a little bit
about support.
You said support
a couple of times
when you were explaining
what it is you do.
But what is support?
What does that actually
mean Google Cloud Platform?
BRIAN DORSEY: What's an
example of a kind of problem
we help with with support?
TERRANCE SHEPHERD:
Good question.
So it really ranges
on the issue.
So we'll help you anything from
any of your billing issues,
like you want to change the
credit card you're paying with,
or you're finally at a point
in which your credit card
limit is less than the bill
you have on Cloud Platform.
So we'll help you get to the
next level of paying via wire
transfer or we call
it offline billing,
where it's not like a credit
card that's charged each week.
We'll help you with bugs you
think might be in the system.
We'll help you get all the
information needed and required
to report it to engineering.
We'll work with engineering
to make sure they're actually
working on the bugs.
So customers who are
running into issues
don't get that anymore.
We work on things prior to even
customers reporting problems.
So we look at products
before they even
get in customer hands.
We'll look at the
error messages that
are going to be generated
and be like, hey,
is that an error message
that a customer can actually
use and figure out
their own problem?
We very much want people to
come and ask us questions.
But at the same
time we want people
to be able to use the product
without having to come to us,
only coming to us when they're
in a very, very odd situation.
MARK MANDEL: Gotcha.
So you're both helping people
directly and systematically
improving things so that
that help isn't even needed
in the future.
Is that true?
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: Yeah.
Basically.
Well--
MARK MANDEL: Sometimes, please.
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: We
want to keep our jobs.
But at the same time, we
don't want to keep our jobs.
All right?
BRIAN DORSEY: So you're
actually kind of try
to make things better so that
you can move on to deeper
and deeper things rather than--
TERRANCE SHEPHERD:
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We don't want to be your
typical support team.
We want to be the people that
you partner with and help grow
your company on our platform.
When you have the questions, the
tough, the nitty gritty stuff,
we want to be the team you
come to or you ask advice to.
We don't want to be the team
you go to when it's like, oh,
I got an error.
We're happy to do
that type of stuff.
But we don't want you
to have to come to us
for that type of question.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
BRIAN DORSEY: So that
takes it even further
than we usually
think about support.
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: Yeah.
We're really not your
average support team.
We very much try to be the
best at what we can do.
We spend a lot of time--
well, I think a lot of people
spend a lot of time
interacting with support teams.
And your cell phone
providers, you
have to go to them because
something's not working right,
not to knock any
cell phone providers.
But sometimes when
you go to them
they're not always the most
helpful people they can be.
And that's like
the number one goal
for us is be the most helpful.
We aren't going to just reject
you or say we can't help you.
We're actually going
to try to answer
whatever the question is as long
as it's within what we can do.
BRIAN DORSEY: So what
are those parameters?
Are they broken up into
groups or what can we do?
Is it programmed in tiers or--
TERRANCE SHEPHERD:
So we technically
support all of the products
under the Google Cloud
Platform.
But sometimes that confuses
some of our customers.
Sometimes we get questions
for like, oh, we have-- like,
oh, I ran out of
quota on the Maps API.
Maps API technically
isn't under cloud.
Even though its
an API and it used
to be in the
developer's console,
we sometimes get
questions for that.
But if you have a question
with Translate API,
that's under the cloud umbrella,
the Vision API app engine.
Those are all the sorts of
products we really help with.
BRIAN DORSEY: Gotcha.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So if I have a question-- say
I'm writing on Google Cloud
Platform, like where do I go?
Does it matter if I'm on a
different support package,
or do I all go to
the same place,
or what avenues are
available to me?
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: So if you're
on one of our higher tiers,
so silver, gold, or platinum, we
always recommend that you come.
You sign into the
Google For Work
Support Center, which is how you
file cases with various support
teams here at Google.
It's where you file
support cases with my team.
And we always recommend
you come to us first.
If you're on the
bronze level, you
can post your questions on the
Stack Overflow or the Google
Groups public issue trackers.
And they're all there and
monitored by our team.
But it's not where you can
get one-to-one support.
If you want individual
customized responses
and questions, the Google
For Work Support Center
is going to your best place.
But if we see a
question and we think
it's going to benefit
the community,
we have a whole team of
people that sit and watch
all of those mediums and
will answer questions
if it's going to benefit
the entire community.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
So going up through the tiers--
you were talking about bronze,
silver, gold,
platinum-- I believe
everyone is enrolled
in bronze immediately,
just because you're part of
the Google Cloud Platform.
Is that correct?
TERRANCE SHEPHERD:
That is correct.
BRIAN DORSEY: Excellent.
OK.
And that's what gives you--
as soon as you're there,
like bronze is really-- that's
where you're reaching out
to support through what
you're talking about.
So there's community mediums.
There's developer
communities, Stack Overflow.
And those things are monitored
by the support engineers.
Is that correct?
TERRANCE SHEPHERD:
That is correct.
Yeah.
We have a whole
team that monitors
all of what we call a one
to many support mediums.
BRIAN DORSEY: And
then you'll also
interact with other people
using Google Cloud there, people
who other customers,
other users,
other people with
similar experience
in those public communities?
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: Yeah.
Some of our bigger
communities, such as-- the it's
called GCE Discuss
or GCE Discussion.
It's a Google group.
It's actually really popular
with members of the community
actually helping each other.
And support actually
doesn't have
to provide a lot of
help or nurturing
in those types of situations.
And actually, community
is really active there.
You'll also find a lot
of our product engineers
on Stack Overflow.
They all follow most
of Stack Overflow.
Most teams that have
a Stack Overflow tag
also follow along and
provide answers there.
I know the BigQuery team,
you will actually get answers
from real BigQuery engineers.
BRIAN DORSEY: Oh, awesome.
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: Like, if
you have questions there,
like I don't quite understand
how this function works,
BigQuery engineers are there.
And they go, hey, yeah.
Here's this.
And then they bring
back the information.
And actually, they improve
their documentation usually.
BRIAN DORSEY: That's fantastic.
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: Yeah.
They answer the question.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
So the silver, gold,
and platinum, those do
cost extra money, right?
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: So I see they
all have different benefits
to those.
But I think I know the
answer to this question.
But I'm going to ask it anyway.
What do you think is
the one big reason
for why people should
pay for support
at Google Cloud Platform?
TERRANCE SHEPHERD:
So the reason why
people should pay for support
is the tailored experience.
In the Google Group
forums or Stack Overflow,
the answers to the
questions is going
to be generic and try
to help facilitate
a conversation for a
wide variety of audience,
people coming to it later.
In the paid support, you get
tailored one-to-one answers
that address your
very specific needs
and usually involve
exactly what you're doing.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
And I say also in the gold
level it's not just hey,
I've got a problem.
But I believe it's also like
I'm trying to find the best
way to do this.
Can you help me work that out?
Is that true?
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: Yeah.
That's something we do
actually quite regularly.
And I have some
really great stories
about things along those lines.
BRIAN DORSEY: Oh, let's hear it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Let's hear them.
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: Yeah.
So one of them--
we had a customer.
they're a really
big video game now.
But before they got really
big they called us up
and they're like, hey,
we have a problem.
And we sat there.
And we helped them.
And we actually had two
different support reps
sit on the phone with them
for eight hours one day,
eight hours the next
day, and then four
hours on the third day.
And we actually helped it.
It was actually quite
interesting to watch
to see like the support
rep and the customer--
they'd have conversations.
And they'd be agreed,
be like, all right.
Let's go grab a snack.
We'll come back in
15 minutes and we'll
continue the conversation.
These are kind of
the types of things
that we don't mind doing.
And it's part of that
like additional help.
And really, they were having
some issues around Cloud SQL.
And we were helping them
get past the growing
pains that some customers
experience with Cloud SQL.
MARK MANDEL: Brilliant.
So it sounds like it's really
great, not just the hey,
I've got a problem, but I
haven't used this platform
before, and I have built
this particular thing before.
And it allows you to kind
of have that sanity check
or like that extra
pair of eyes to be
able to see am I not
doing something completely
and utterly crazy.
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: Yeah.
Most of the support reps
generally pass a full Google
engineering interview.
And so we all have experience
with distributed systems
and scaling systems.
And so actually, where you get
the best benefit from the gold
and platinum support
is actually people
who have done these things.
And so in this case
with this past customer
they had a proof of concept.
It was running on Google SQL.
And then they tried to throw
like 200 times load at it.
And they're like, it fell over.
And so we're helping
them facilitate
through those types of things.
BRIAN DORSEY: What's the
solution there because I
want this to scale up.
I'm going to get 200
times on my project too.
What's the answer.
TERRANCE SHEPHERD:
Sure, you will.
So actually this was before
Cloud SQL was-- or, Cloud
SQL V2 was a big thing.
And so we actually helped them
install, and configure, and low
test my SQL running on GCE.
And that helped him
out quite a bit.
BRIAN DORSEY: And
if someone were
running with a similar
situation today, what
would the recommendation be?
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: Cloud SQL V2.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK.
It's that much faster?
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: Yeah.
So Cloud SQL V1 has a
couple of limitations,
like the number of
connections you could have
or how big it is.
And the way this
customer was going,
they needed a lot more power.
And so Cloud SQL V2 wasn't
quite ready, even for beta
at the time.
And so really, I would
recommend it now.
It's many more connections,
much bigger instances.
It's pretty amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So that sounds like a
pretty specific case.
Are there any common
things that people often
come to support for, things
you often see quite regularly?
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: Yeah.
There's a couple things.
Most of them actually come
from either GCE or Cloud SQL.
There seems to be a trend here.
So connection
limits in Cloud SQL
is something that
happens all the time.
Something else that
happens from Cloud SQL
is sometimes we have to perform
maintenance on your instances.
And so sometimes
they get rebooted
as part of the maintenance.
But customers like to enable
a flag called the general log
on their Cloud SQL instances.
And so even though we've
rebooted your instance,
and it was only down for 15
seconds as we rebooted it,
sometimes it can take up to
five hours for your Cloud SQL
instance to recover
because it's trying
to go through the general log.
BRIAN DORSEY: Wow.
OK.
Wait.
How do we avoid this on my thing
that's going to go to 200x?
TERRANCE SHEPHERD:
So Cloud SQL V2
allows you to add
your own My SQL flags.
So just don't add the enable
general log My SQL flag.
BRIAN DORSEY: And we're OK?
OK.
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: Yeah.
But that's something
that happens quite often.
So the general log is
really good for debugging.
But people forget
to disable it when
they go live into production.
And so they get bitten by
this, most around 30 minutes.
But and then customers
try to reboot there
because you can do that
once it comes back up.
You can reboot your
Cloud SQL instance.
And so they only actually
cause themselves more pain when
they click the reboot button.
BRIAN DORSEY: It just
takes that much longer.
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: Yeah.
They'll get 15
minutes in and reboot.
So really, you just
got to be patient.
You got to wait.
There's nothing we can
do for your instance.
You just got to wait.
So disable your gentle logs.
Make sure those are disabled.
BRIAN DORSEY: Got you.
Lesson for the day.
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: Yeah.
Rule number one in Cloud SQL,
don't enable the general log.
MARK MANDEL: That's a
great lesson for the day.
TERRANCE SHEPHERD:
On GCE some of things
that sometimes catch customers
is the log migrations.
We try to make them as
painless as possible.
But there are some pieces
of software out there
that can't handle five
seconds of the network
not being available.
So distributed
clustered systems,
like sub-millisecond or
sub-second heartbeats.
And if you fail two of
them, your node's dead.
And so we've handled that a
couple of times and being like,
yeah.
Live migration sometimes
can take one or two seconds.
And your software's health beats
are a little too aggressive.
So if you can turn
them down, you
won't have to do manual recovery
of your [INAUDIBLE] system
every time there's
a lot of migration.
So those are the common
ones that I-- well,
another common one is
actually firewall rules.
Those trip people
up all the time.
I was actually
handling one today
where some customers really
like to limit their firewall
rules to be their
office's IP address.
But very few people actually
have a static IP address.
And so when their office, the
IP address of their office
changes, they're like, why
can't I SSH into my instances?
The IP address
you're trying to log
in as different than your
firewall rules allow.
So you have to coach customers
through those sorts of things.
BRIAN DORSEY: Gotcha.
So I'm on a cable connection
or something in my office.
And its on [INAUDIBLE] DNS.
And one day it just changes.
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: Yeah.
Sometimes I see a
customer's firewall rules.
And it's Brian's
home IP address.
And I can't log in from home.
And it's like, yep.
Looks like your IP
address changed.
BRIAN DORSEY: So can you just
look at these for customers?
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: Look at what?
BRIAN DORSEY: Like,
my firewall rules.
Can use look at that?
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: Yeah.
I can--
BRIAN DORSEY: Wait, really?
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: With
restrictions, yeah.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK.
How does that work?
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: So first
off, you need to tell me
that there's a problem.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK.
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: And then
as with everything at Google,
everything is logged and you
need a reason to do anything.
So when you submit a case, I
can look at the metainformation
of your project, so
which firewalls you have
and which instances you have.
I can't actually log
into any of them.
But I can see the name
of your instances.
So if you're like oh, my
web server 01 is acting up,
I can actually go and see which
instance in your project is
that and then be able to
inspect information about it,
like how much CPU it's
using, how much disc and RAM
it's using.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK.
As part of requesting
support, but I'm
kind of asking you to be able
to take a look at metadata
around the project.
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: Yes.
It would be really
hard to do our job
without being able to do that.
Or, the alternative is
we play the game of can
you run this G-Cloud command
and send me he output.
And so that is a possibility.
But it's not the
most efficient way
for us to help you
solve your problem.
And when you're already anxious
and you're down in production,
you'd rather we
just tell you how
to solve the problem then ask
you to run 15 commands for us.
BRIAN DORSEY: Gotcha.
MARK MANDEL: That
make a lot of sense.
I wanted to return a little
bit to the different tiers
in support so that
people can have
a feel for what tier they
might want to use depending
on where they're at with their
Google Cloud Platform usage.
Bronze seems very obvious
because you're already
signed in.
We talk a little bit about
silver I think to the degree
that you're like, OK.
You get the
personalized experience.
For me, looking
at gold, it seems
like the big win there is you
get that consultative ticket.
So you get that ability
to be able to ask,
give me a guide on how
to build this thing.
I've never done it before.
At what point do you
think people should be
moving to from silver to gold?
Is it just because
they have that need?
And then also, what
point do you think
people should be moving
from gold to platinum?
TERRANCE SHEPHERD:
So the big thing,
I think, changing
from silver to gold,
is when you need
that 24 by 7 support.
That's really the big difference
between silver and gold,
is when your stuff is
down on the weekend
and you need someone to
answer your questions
so your business is back up and
running, gold is the right one.
MARK MANDEL: And specifically
that's phone support as well?
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: Yeah,
phone support as well.
And so even if you look
at the target response
times on things-- so when
you're down in production,
I would call that a P1
ticket, like priority one.
I'm down.
I'm losing money.
We target to respond
within one hour.
When you're on the silver
level, the target to response
is four business hours.
So if you're down
on the weekend,
it could be up till 1 o'clock
Australian time on a Monday
when we would start
responding to you.
So if you're on
the Pacific time,
it would be about 9
o'clock PM Sunday.
And then from gold to silver,
or from gold to platinum,
it's only an extension of that.
So we target responses
in 15 minutes.
So if you're a
really big customer,
and you lose thousands,
tens of thousands,
millions per a minute down,
platinum's the place to be.
MARK MANDEL: That makes sense.
BRIAN DORSEY: And it looks
like the other difference
there is this critical impact
issues versus high impact
issues.
What's the difference there?
TERRANCE SHEPHERD:
So critical impact
is system is down,
in production,
and I'm losing money.
High impact, it's
hard to describe.
But things just short
of that are high impact.
It's always hard to
just-- so it would
be classified as priority.
So P1s are like systems down
and losing money in production.
P2, it would be high impact.
It's always hard to
describe what a P2 is.
So we support you on
weekends with P2 stuff.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK.
So I notice the disk
is filling or some sort
of like performance degradation.
Things are trending towards
bad, but they haven't actually
failed yet.
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: Yeah.
Not that it happens often,
but let's say for example
you're putting a lot
of objects into GCS.
And GCS, as example, GCS
has an error rate of 1%.
And you start seeing GCS
go to 2%, 3%, 4%, or 5%.
That would be a time to file
a P2 ticket on platinum,
well, if you had
platinum, and tell us hey.
GSC error rates are going up.
Our engineering team should
already be aware of it.
But that would be
a P2 thing of we're
kind of going towards
the bad situation.
Can you identify and solve
it before we are actually
down in production?
MARK MANDEL: OK.
Brilliant.
OK.
So we're starting to run out
of time just a little bit.
But all the support stuff
sounds really great.
So how do I sign up?
What's the best
way to get started?
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: So you can
sign up for silver and gold
just by clicking the buttons
on cloud.google.com/support.
It will actually tell
you how to do it.
For platinum support, it
requires a little more work
and a little more effort.
Usually involves a
sales team member
to actually start the process
in an offline contract,
not necessarily strictly there.
But that's generally
how the process goes.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
But I can access
buttons for that
to get in contact through
that same URL I believe.
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
BRIAN DORSEY: All right.
And is there anything
else about support
that we haven't
covered, or you'd
want to say, or plug, or
anything extra you want to add?
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: Probably
only thing to add is that--
or to reiterate--
is that the people
you're talking on the other end
are basically Google engineers.
It's the same people that
comes out of same talent
pool as [INAUDIBLE] at Google.
And they just have
some extra skills
that we think make them
good to be in this position.
BRIAN DORSEY: That's awesome.
MARK MANDEL: That
is very, very cool.
All right.
Well, Terrance and
Brian, thank you
so much for joining me today and
joining us here on the Google
Cloud Platform podcast.
That was a super
interesting conversation.
TERRANCE SHEPHERD: Thanks.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
thank you so much,
Terrance, for taking the
time to talk to us today--
actually, not to us, but
to talk to Brian and Mark.
Thank you, Brian, also for
helping us with this interview.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
He jumped in because I had
to reschedule everything
because I managed to
hurt myself with my dog.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That's a long story.
But fortunately,
everything is fine.
And Brian is-- he's
actually awesome.
Not only he's helping
us having good Mics,
now he's also helping
us interviewing people.
Next step he will actually just
run the podcast by himself.
MARK MANDEL: Probably.
Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
which is totally fine.
I'm looking forward to that.
Cool.
So let's go with the
question of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
So we're talking about
this a little before.
Basically, it runs
along the lines
of-- say you have your app
running on something like App
Engine and you want to connect
to one of the other Google
services that run in the
cloud such as Calendar,
or possibly Drive.
I've had this question
before as well.
I have no idea how to do it.
But I do believe
you do, Fransesc.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And I actually got
this same question
but in a slightly different way.
And I'm going to
share it because I
thought it was really cool.
There was these people that
were doing a little application
where you could take a picture.
This picture could be sent
to the Cloud Vision API.
They could do OCR, so character
recognition on that image,
and then create a new
document on Google Docs
we text recognize
from the image, which
I thought it was very useful.
MARK MANDEL: That's cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah.
So the [INAUDIBLE] is like-- OK.
So Google Cloud Vision API--
obviously. you used the API.
How do you do the
docs part of it.
And there's actually a
couple ways of doing it.
But the easiest one is using
the simply the REST API.
Most Google services,
they provide an API.
And it's mostly REST APIs.
There's also sometimes
the GRPC APIs.
But you're going to see REST
APIs, which means that you
can use them from anywhere.
You can use them very
easily from your own machine
if you want to try them out.
There's also something
that I think that people
should know about if.
If you have never tried it,
it's Google API's Explorer,
which is actually basically
a playground where you
can see all the APIs we offer.
And then you can directly
form there just fill the gaps,
like fill the fields
that you want to try.
And they just run it.
And it manages all the
authentication part of it.
So it's very nice.
But obviously, you
can also do that
from any language
running anywhere.
So you can do it directly
from the compute engine,
from container engine.
And if you're doing
it from App Engine,
you're going to need to use
things like QRL Fetch, which
allows you to do ATP requests
from an App Engine instance
to the outside world.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Now, do I need to build
those REST requests myself,
are there any SDKs
or client tools
that I could use to make my
life a little bit easier?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That is a very good question.
So if you are the
kind of person that
wants to create everything
by himself, by themselves,
it's totally fine.
You can totally do that.
But we also offer a
bunch of libraries
that basically offer
the same functionality,
but an idiomatic way.
So for instance,
for Google Docs,
you can see that there is Java,
JavaScript.net, Objective C,
PHP, Python, and then also DART
and GO, obviously, and Node.js,
Ruby.
And I'm pretty sure there's
even more than that.
But basically, all
of those libraries
are developed
sometimes by engineers.
So basically, they're
going to be very idiomatic.
And they're going to feel
like normal libraries.
Sometimes for other services you
will see that they are actually
autogenerated.
So they will not
be as idiomatic.
But still, it's
easier than writing
the whole requests yourself.
MARK MANDEL: That
makes a lot of sense.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah.
So you can check it out.
We'll have the links
in the show notes.
And that way you can easy
integrate Google Cloud
applications with
Google services.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
That sounds really great.
Excellent.
Well, we both seem to be a
little bit out and about.
But any particular
events you're going
to be at in the next
few weeks, Francesc?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I've heard
about this conference that
sounds very interesting.
I think it's called Google IO.
MARK MANDEL: I've
heard about this.
What is that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I don't know, but it's going to
be happening in Mountain View.
So yeah.
I'll be there.
We'll be there.
MARK MANDEL: We'll be there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I'm going to be speaking
about Google Cloud Spin.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
I will be there also talking
about multiplayer games
with Firebase.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And after that, I will go
to Chicago for my first time
ever for GOTO.
MARK MANDEL: Very nice.
I'll also be standing
around at some of the areas
we'll have at Google IO.
So you can come and talk
to Googlers, and to chat
to us about your
problems, or things
you want to solve as well.
So definitely swing by.
I'll be there as well
as many of my peers.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Yeah.
I'll be also there wearing
Google Cloud Platform podcast
T-shirt.
MARK MANDEL: I would never
take that T-shirt off.
I am constantly
wearing that T-shirt.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
You're actually
wearing it right now.
MARK MANDEL: I am
Absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's amazing.
Just for people to know,
we have more than one.
So we actually washed them.
There's more than one Google
Cloud Platform T-shirt, Google
Cloud Platform Podcast T-shirt.
There you go.
Great.
So before we say
goodbye, why don't we
remind people how to
contact us, because I think
there's something new today.
MARK MANDEL: There is
something new today.
There's a new URL that
you can reach our website.
I know it doesn't
seem like a big thing.
You can get to us
at GCPpodcast.com.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It is a huge thing.
MARK MANDEL: It's pretty cool.
No.
You can get to us at
cloud.google.com/podcast.
It makes us feel
very, very official,
or even extra official.
But yeah.
Cloud.google.com/podcast will
take you to GCPpodcast.com
and the two of us.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, very cool.
Also, if you want
to send us an email,
you can send it
hello@gcppodcast.com.
We're also on Twitter.
MARK MANDEL: At @GCPpodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We are
also on Google Plus.
MARK MANDEL: As PlusGCPpodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
have a sub-Reddit.
MARK MANDEL: At slash
R slash GCPpodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And a Slack
community-- no-- Slack channel.
MARK MANDEL: Slack
community, yeah.
Inside the Slack community, we
have a channels hash podcast
that you can reach
us at as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And I'm
almost sure I'm forgetting
something as usual, but--
MARK MANDEL: No.
I think that's it.
I think we're good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Wow.
Amazing.
I remember all of them.
Cool.
So thank you very much, Mark,
to take time off your trip
to Kentucky to
record this episode.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely,
wouldn't miss it for the world.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And looking forward
to talking to you next week
face to face next time.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
See you back in San
Francisco next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See you.
Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]